what's the sun's problem anyway well
like any other star it has an expiration
date the beginning of its end will
feature our sun swelling into a red
giant wiping out everything that happens
to be orbiting it too closely like the
Earth if we wanted to survive we'd need
to take action long before the sun
started going on a
rampage it would take a billion space
shuttles to evacuate about 7 and a half
billion Earthlings
even if we could launch 1,000 space
shuttles every day it would take over
2700 years to move everyone off the
doomed
Planet maybe we could save ourselves
some trouble by moving our whole planet
instead that's actually quite possible
we'd only need to give the Earth one big
boost in the right direction and keep it
on course